hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to reading your
comments how do you unkilled Adam and Q
mark please I need to know how to take
good selfies soon I will die hard oppose
would be what command you to quit
selfies mark I gots to know how I get
the ladies to do the sex with me
you're still probably still probably
won't have that [ __ ] at least this is
Booga Booga mulattoes bookie scary mark
are you gonna continue with your blank
dream series yes I plan to finish that
all in one episode I apologize for
leaving that where it was but that was
right before everything kind of got in a
crisis mode so I will get back to it
very soon
hey Mark I hope you see this I'm very
curious if you were to have a son
someday would you hope he was in the
games and playing them with you since
that's how you and your dad bonded when
you were young lots of love from
Columbus Ohio well actually me and my
dad didn't play too many games together
he was the one that introduced me to
games and introduced me to the concept
of playing games but to be frank me and
my brother bonded more over games than
me and my dad did not to say that's not
that I bonded over my dad my dad was
just a person that commanded so much
respect in my life that it was never a
question that I was bonded to him so my
dad I loved very much growing up but if
I had a son I it wouldn't matter to me
what he did so long as like he looks up
to me the same way that I looked up to
my dad like my dad was the perfect
example of what a dad should be and I
would hope that if I were to ever become
a dad to a son or a daughter that they
would just look to me with respect in
the same way that I look to my dad
that's the only thing I could ever hope
for as a parent now that being said and
despite what happened in the last video
I don't plan to be a dad anytime soon if
you love space so much why didn't you go
and do astronomy well I mean it's like I
just because I love space doesn't mean
that I wanted to make it my career like
if I had the possibility or i
realistically considered myself being an
astronaut maybe I would have gone down
that path but the the chances of that
happening were obscurely low I can still
appreciate space for what it is and heck
not that it's gonna happen but if ever
the possibility that I could go into
space happened I would jump at the
opportunity but in the meantime I can
appreciate space as a hobby and then
continue in my life doing everything
else just because you know it's the
possibility of focusing your life into
something super specific and only going
after that you know you can do that but
like the way I live my life instead I
try to branch out into as many things as
possible that I love and then appreciate
that for what it is and then always hold
my love of space because just because
I'm doing it from an amateur perspective
doesn't mean that I don't get so much
more enjoyment out of it
from a distance so Marc yo so fat well
if that was Spanish it means Marc I so
fat so I want a pony
Marc hasn't done LSD but he has done
crack I actually remember that because
when I first came to LA there was this
big rumor that I had started doing crack
and it boggled my mind because people
jumped from me I've never done crack in
my life or else tea oral great many
drugs I know there's a whole repertoire
of wondrous horrible drugs out there to
try I have tried none of them thank you
very much but frankly there was it's
huge rumor that when I came to LA I had
started doing crack and I forget the
specific reason why but people just
automatically jump that they were very
worried about me and there was this huge
subset of people that were like oh no
Marc's life is just going into turmoil
he started doing crack and he's doing
drugs that he's gonna spiral down into
the LA lifestyle and boo-hoo-hoo-hoo I'm
fine I don't do drugs I don't even drink
anymore so I am as square as could be
I was so square I still use the term
square are you going on a medal anytime
soon I would really like to test my luck
again finding you cuz last time I
couldn't yes I would love to do omegle
again I would love to do an omegle event
because in the past I tried to do it and
in the past I made the mistake of trying
to be around for eight hours to get to
everybody but what that led to was even
more disappointment because people had
been waiting for eight hours trying to
find
and then didn't find me because even in
eight hours you can only get to about
100 or 200 people when thousands and
thousands are trying to find me and even
now now that I have 10 million
subscribers it would be even worse of
people trying to find me so if I do it
again I'm only going to be looking for
one to two hours and spread that out
over a few days that way people you know
have an opportunity to find me but
they're not wasting their entire day
trying to get on omegle with me so I
will do an amygdala vent very soon I
will let you know when that's happening
music can we expect a Christmas elf I'm
not even joking hey if you're not even
joking I will legitimately do it if
there's enough people out there that
want me to do it let me know in the
comments below and I will legitimately
make an amateur Christmas album and I
will release it for entirely free let me
know what songs you want to hear of the
Christmas spirit I am not joking mark
have you ever tried British candy if so
what do you think of it actually no I
have never tried British candy I do want
to go to London someday or England
someday but if anyone has any
recommendations of British candy and
getting British candy and how to get
that I will do a video trying British
candy if people want to see that so
let's recommend me in the comments below
what you want me to eat not eat it and
I'll react to it and be horribly
disgusted by your stupid English candy
unless it's great and then I'll love
your English candy but it's slang you
know you don't know which gotta have a
sound hit it if you're planning on
making music what digital audio
workstation software would you use and
what hardware do you plan on using um I
would probably actually I have my whole
I have my whole little workstation set
up over in the other corner of this room
and I'm gonna be using Pro Tools because
that's what Daniel kind of introduced me
to and that's what he worked on so I
kind of want to use that but I will
admit Pro Tools anti-piracy [ __ ] is
the worst most intrusive [ __ ] I've ever
seen in my life it is so hard to legit
and I paid for it I paid I'm paying for
Pro Tools and I can't use it yet I am
like emailing customer service back and
forth trying to get to the point where I
can actually use their stupid [ __ ]
software but look it's it's like I'm a
paying
Simar ProTools i can't use your [ __ ]
what is wrong just it infuriates me like
I get it I get it software companies you
don't want people pirating your software
but come on it's you're making it so
impossible for legitimate paying
customers I imagine it would be easier
if I just pirated the dumb thing you
can't make it so that your software is
so hard to use that it's easier pirated
that's so stupid
so if anyone has any other
recommendations for a digital audio
workstation let me know besides Pro
Tools because frankly I'd be ok with
changing markiplier would you consider
yourself more of a bodybuilder or a
CrossFit person also the baby is coming
for you hide what my baby that's gonna
be born on the Internet is that what
you're talking about my baby's coming
afternoon should I run away from my
responsibilities actually I don't work
out much that actually probably comes as
a bit of shock because I am naturally
muscular I'm naturally uh more in in
shape just because I don't know it's
just I have good genes so I I look good
even though I don't work out like I've
wanted to like actually see how in shape
I could get if I really did stick to a
schedule but playing video games is so
fun and watching movies and eating junk
food is so fun so I don't know like give
me yeah you know what right now I'm
gonna promise right now I'm gonna start
working out I'm gonna start working out
regularly and I'm gonna see just how fit
I could get because I want to know I
really legitimately want to know because
I I'm being totally a hundred percent
honest here I don't work out on a
regular basis ask any of my friends I
don't and if I did I could probably look
really really good and that's not just
me bragging to you guys that's like a
like a personal goal at Cana you want to
get back in shape I I can't even run up
the stairs without getting completely
winded so I will do my best I will work
out and I will try to get back to shape
hey Mark just wanted to say how much I
enjoyed the little things you do I feel
like happiness is made of small little
moments so I just want to say thank you
for always making me laugh and smile and
for looking at the camera every time you
look at the camera it just makes your
videos so much better oh well thank you
very much I didn't know that
something like looking at the camera
could make people really smile I mean
when I make videos I always try to keep
in mind that I'm connecting with an
audience when I'm doing it because even
though I'm in my room alone and it seems
like I'm insane talking to myself
sometimes I always try to remember that
you guys are out there and I always try
to appreciate the fact that you guys are
with me on my videos because I don't
look at my videos in making my videos as
like a professional project in any way
not that it is professional what I do I
always try to try to make it seem like
we're all on the world's biggest couch
watching a game when we play it together
and then when I do like my my [ __ ]
videos where I make the fake movie
trailer for best fiends and I do other
cool stuff like the unnecessary
censorship and the mini montages like I
always try to do that as like I look at
it like you know that friend that sends
you the random [ __ ] at any time of
day and you'll pick it up and you'll
just go ahh what is he doing with his
life like I want to be that guy to you
guys I'm gonna be the guy that you're
just like oh come on but you kind of
chuckle a little bit because it's
annoying but at the same time it's kind
of funny so you know that's that's the
kind of guy hoping to be to you guys so
I I really am glad that it's the little
things that make you feel happy so and
just knowing that what I do makes people
happy out there is really the greatest
reward of what I do so thank you guys so
much for appreciating and I'm glad you
enjoy the things that I do so art for
your next reading of Commons can you
answer this question for me do you think
marching band is a sport to be honest I
don't really care what's defined as a
sport or not because I'm not a sports
person I don't watch sports I I don't
appreciate sports I don't even like the
whole sports culture like rooting for
the home team fan stuff like that III
don't get it I don't appreciate it
myself and I don't understand why other
people go so rabid about it not that I
criticize them for doing it they're more
than welcome to do whatever the hell
they want to Who am I to criticize what
they do with their life but frankly if
marching band is considered a sport what
does it matter like what does that
matter to you it doesn't matter what
it's called of or considered it's matter
what enjoyment you get out of it like if
you like doing marching band more
- you do it and forget everyone that
criticizes what it is that you do
because what you do doesn't matter to
other people their opinions on what you
do is irrelevant because you do
something for your own enjoyment and not
for the appreciation of others it's
great when they do appreciate what you
do and no matter what you do there will
be some people out there that do
appreciate it but frankly those that
don't it doesn't matter if it's your own
personal enjoyment you got to take what
you have and you got to like appreciate
it for what it is and you got to let it
grow inside you for the personal growth
that it is not for everyone else just
because like some people may hate what
you do or you start out and you're not
good at what you do because everyone
starts out bad at what you do even a
genius virtuoso had to practice hours
and hours and hours to get to where he
is or he or she is it doesn't matter you
just start out and you do it because you
like it and not because other people
hate it you know what I mean okay that's
all for this week's reading your
comments thank you everybody so much for
writing comments down News comment
section below not the description and
remember to let me know if you guys want
to see a Christmas album coming out in
this holiday season and if I should
start working out let me know what you
want me to do with my life because
that's how I dictate it by the opinions
of the internet despite what I just told
you is that you shouldn't do but thank
you everybody so much for watching and
remember to write your comments for me
to read in the next video next week and
also write whatever the hell you want to
say you never know what's gonna make it
in because I always just kind of plan it
by what I think will be funny and what I
think will be profound so thank you
again everybody thank you all so much
for your comments and thank you for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye